OK, everyone.
Good morning.
This is Jack Vanhorn from the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center based at the University
of Southern California.
And I'd like to welcome everyone to the next
in our series of big data to knowledge, guide
to the fundamentals of data science.
Today, we're going to be hearing from Dr.
Zachary Ives from the University of Pennsylvania.
He's going to be discussing data provenance
challenges, benefits, and research.
Dr. Ives is a professor of computer and information
science at the University of Pennsylvania
as well as the newlyappointed Associate Dean
for Masters and Professional Programs at the
University of Penn's School of Engineering
and Applied Science.
He's the co-founder of Blackfin, Inc., which
is a company focused on enabling life sciences
research and discovery through data integration.
And his research interests include data integration,
sharing, management of big data, sensor networks,
data provenance, and authoritativeness.
He's the recipient of an NSF Career Award
and an alumnus of the DARPA Computer Science
Study Panel and Information Science and Technology
Advisory Panels.
He's co-authored textbooks, many influential
articles.
And we're absolutely delighted to hear about
his work on data provenance.
That is the attaching of metadata, but also
by whom that data comes from, under what conditions,
the processing steps that were used, and all
the things that we call provenance.
So Zachary, thank you very much for joining
us.
We really look forward to your lecture.
Great.
Thanks very much, Jack, and thanks, everyone,
for joining.
As Jack said, I have worked on a variety of
topics broadly related to computational support
for bringing together data from many places.
And of course, once you start to integrate
and reuse data, all sorts of questions arise
about where the original data came from, and
how it was assembled, and so on.
And so I see provenance as a key part not
only of data science, but especially of data
science when you're trying to share and reuse
data.
So my goal today is to try to give a high-level
overview of the main abstractions and models
for how we think about provenance, some of
the benefits of provenance, some of the open
challenges, and a little bit of a hint at
where a lot of the open problems in the active
research is in this space.
I should probably note, as I go into this,
that the NIH BD2K program is currently funding
three different efforts in the provenance
space.
So there's our group at Penn, there's a group
out of Case Western, and a group out of Duke,
and we're all trying to work together in a
coordinated fashion to make services that
might be reusable across the broader BD2K
portfolio.
So with that, let me see if I can actually
dive in a little bit into why we actually
care about provenance.
As I do that, I should probably emphasize
there are actually several different terms
used for roughly the same ideas.
So I think
the standard at this point is data provenance.
And in fact, to my best knowledge, the term
was actually coined by my former colleague,
Peter Buneman, here at Penn.
But other people have called it data lineage,
data pedigree, and so on.
And in some sense, really, it's an expanded
version of the scientific record, and the
way we describe our experimental methodology,
and so on.
So as you think about a process like what's
visualized on the slide where we go from data
acquisition to data analysis to generating
figures and reports and papers, all along
the way, we'd like to record in as much detail
as we can-the processes, the assumptions,
the sample size, the sample settings, et cetera
that went into the creation of each of the
data products along the way.
When you look at that, at the very earliest
stage, the left-most, the data acquisition
side, what we tend to think of as provenance
is things like who did the experiment, under
what instrument settings, and what the context
was.
This is largely metadata that we need to carefully
define.
As we move from acquisition of the raw data
from the real world, there typically are a
lot of computational steps performed.
You run a piece of code with an algorithm.
So there, we tend to think about data provenance
as something that might, for instance, be
automatically created, maintained, and logged
by the computer system itself as you're running
your code and so on.
So there's a fairly different way we think
about provenance at the first stage versus
the second stage, because the first stage
is primarily figuring out what you want to
capture.
The second stage is something that you can
imagine computationally supporting and automating.
And I'll get into more detail about that as
we go forward.
With respect to why provenance, obviously,
one of the big motivations for data provenance
is support for reproducibility and validation
of results.
The more documentation we have on exactly
what was done, the more detail we can understand
how to repeat the same results.
But in fact, increasingly, we're starting
to put value on other uses of provenance.
So one of the most important that I've looked
at in my computer science research is if you
have data from many different providers, ultimately,
we can use data provenance and past history
and reliability and so on to actually use
provenance to reason about how much you as
an individual user might want to trust or
rank or look at a particular data source.
So really, the reliability, relevance, or
value of data may also depend very much on
its provenance.
So we tend to think of that generically as
trust, but it really encompasses lots of different
things.
Another key place where provenance comes into
play all the time is if I am bringing together
data that was acquired under different conditions,
as I'm trying to regularize it and harmonize
it in order to conduct some kind of analysis,
I may have to process data from different
sources in different ways.
And that processing might involve more than
just converting
the formats, which we typically do in the
data wrangling stage.
It might also involve regularizing it in some
particular way, particularly paying attention
to things like which populations were studied
in the different sources, and so on.
So data provenance helps us not just reproduce,
but also evaluate and select and assign trustworthiness
to data.
And finally, if we look at data provenance
and we have a bird's eye perspective of what
data sources are used where, then in fact,
much like we do with social networks and the
worldwide web and so on, we can use, for instance,
information about how often a data source
is used to give some indications about how
authoritative or useful or relevant that particular
data source would be.
So you can think of something analogous to
the H index to Google Page Rank or whatever
being applied to data sources if we have visibility
through data provenance.
So lots of different reasons to use it.
I want to stress that data provenance and
data are really going to be tightly linked
in our world view all the time.
Even though we tend to think of data and metadata
as separate things, obviously, this is a kind
of meta data that's extremely useful in understanding
how to interpret a given piece of data.
So that's the basic overview of what I want
to talk about today.
Now what I'm going to do is drill down a little
bit to more formally explain what provenance
needs to be.
So we'll spend a bit of time on that, and
then I'll go through how we actually model
it computationally with tools, and then some
of the applications.
So starting with the formal definition, let's
separate into two camps.
As I said, one of the kinds of data provenance
is provenance over data as we're acquiring
it.
So for instance, in the figure here, we have
an MRI machine.
We might need to annotate the individual images
or the set of images with information about
what the instrument settings were, who did
the actual experiment or data acquisition,
potentially who the subject was, what experiment
was being done, and so on.
And if you think of the classic questions
of who, what, where, when, why, and how, basically,
what we're trying to do is capture all of
those-- the environment, the context, the
questions, et cetera.
All of this is ultimately fairly domain-specific.
It will depend on what the experiments are
about.
But it does involve some piece of capturing
data from the instrument itself, and it may
involve some additional data entry from the
people actually doing the data acquisition.
So one of the big challenges here is, at some
level, data provenance, if you think of it
as an explanation of exactly why you were
doing some particular data acquisition, can
be an extremely, extremely detailed record
of what you've done before and a justification
for what you're doing now.
We never want to make provenance capture too
much of a burden, so the question is just
how much of this context needs to be captured.
And I think here, when we think about data
provenance, the key challenge is trying to
decide exactly what kind of metadata we're
going to capture that balances between how
hard it is and how much manual labor is involved
versus the level of detail captured that might
help somebody else in the future reinterpret
and reuse our data.
So this first stage is really primarily a
metadata design problem as opposed to a computational
tools problem.
We have to think about things like how much
of the context of the data acquisition can
we get, how much is actually going to be useful
in the future.
Certainly, one of the big questions, especially
with modern sensors and data acquisition devices,
is if we can capture a lot of that context
automatically where a human doesn't have to
do anything, that's extraordinarily helpful.
And there are lots and lots of examples of
this happening in practice.
My collaborators, who do high-throughput gene
sequencing, there's a lot of parameter information
that comes out of that machine.
Whenever you take a digital photo on your
smartphone, there's the so-called EXIF data
that includes all sorts of information about
the settings and potentially even GPS and
so on.
Increasingly, people are looking at using
NFC or barcodes or various other things to
automatically capture their setup in the real
world so that nobody has to manually type
in, or even worse, hand-write in the metadata.
So in general, lots of questions here with
no standardized across the world, across domain
guidelines, but rather, some general rules
of thumb on what you are trying to capture.
However, there are also lots of standards
available at this point for what to capture
in what fields, and how to name them, and
what units with respect to this initial data
acquisition.
And so for instance, one of the standards
bodies that our group interacts with quite
often is Open mHealth.
They have a set of predefined fields for a
lot of kinds of data acquisition tasks that
they've tried to standardize across the community.
Generally here, this is a standards effort
that focuses on particular domains.
Technology can help, for instance, by automating
capture.
But much like database design, the key tasks
here are human-intensive and involve capturing
the experimental setup.
Where the more computational and software
support can come in is when we switch from
that initial data acquisition to later processing
of the data.
So what I have here in the slide is a very
simple sketch of some kind of gene sequence
capture and alignment job where we might start
off on the left with gene sequence information
from initial data acquisition which was captured
with some additional metadata going through
these two red boxes that represent computational
steps.
For instance, in a Python script, the first
one might filter out low-quality sequence
information.
The second one might be actually trying to
align the gene sequences against some reference
genome producing some set of alignments.
So as we look at this, there are multiple
computational steps.
There was provenance in terms of metadata
attached to the original sequence data.
Now the question is what do we attach to the
output of the quality filter, what do we attach
to the output of the aligner, and ideally,
can we build tools that help us do that automatically.
And then ultimately, once we've captured it,
can we build tools that help us to reason
about and make use of this kind of provenance
metadata.
So conceptually, what we want to do is take
those computational steps and essentially
create a trace or a log of here are the individual
steps.
Each step involved certain inputs.
It had certain parameters and produced a certain
output.
So schematically, on the right, you see a
list of steps, like read a particular file,
do some computation like sorting rows, do
some computation, for instance, by computing
a median, do some computation like writing
to a file.
That is a kind of an example of what we might
want to capture to document our computational
processes.
And then, of course, we want to attach it
to our output.
So from a tooling perspective, what we want
is, for instance, to be able to run a script
that automates the production of output results
from input files, and we want to potentially
store that output, either in the file system
or in a database.
And effectively, on the side, what we'd like
is something equivalent to a provenance database
system whose content will also link closely
to the file, as we schematically see in the
right-hand of the figure.
Again, we need to be able to reason about
provenance and data together, because we will
often want to assess the data or interpret
the data based on its linked provenance annotations.
So conceptually, it's a simple problem.
Of course, when you try to actually break
it down into solvable steps, it ends up getting
a little more complicated.
So let's start with a simple, obvious first
take at it.
I'll describe why we need to slightly tweak
that and then where that ultimately has taken
the data provenance community.
So the simplest form of capturing data provenance
is, again, during our initial data acquisition,
as we read data from an instrument, we'll
attach to the file specific metadata tags
and values, for instance, about the experiment,
and the configuration, and date of acquisition,
and the subject, and whatever else is relevant
to our particular experiment.
Then, as we support computational processing,
we could build some kind of service that essentially
captures all of the events that the computer
is handling as it, for instance, launches
a program, opens a file, writes to another
file, reads from another file, starts another
script, and so on and so forth.
So we can monitor program execution, capture
the program-specific events or tasks, feed
it to some logging service, and then put it
into an event log, which we might think of
as a primitive provenance database.
And in fact, in the computer science world,
there are a lot of different research efforts
that have been undertaken
using exactly this model.
Probably the most well known was Margo's Seltzer's
work at Harvard on a system called Pass, which
basically updated the operating system to
record all of the individual steps in reading
and writing to files.
And in fact, more recently, my own group has
built a system we call Provenance Tracker,
which I'll talk about in more detail later,
which does something similar without changing
the operating system.
It essentially captures all of the data processing
steps in terms of jobs being run and inputs
and outputs, and then it makes it accessible
for the future.
So there are lots of tools for doing this.
The nice thing about these tools is they capture
all the individual steps, the inputs and outputs,
automatically.
We don't have to worry about a human entering
all of that information.
There also is a very related thing that happens
at pretty much every internet company and
any large enterprise, which is very close
to provenance, but people tend to not think
of it that way, which is as they process data,
they record logs and logs and logs of requests,
for instance, from the web server, of individual
queries handled, of individual steps performed.
All of that stuff is really capturing a kind
of data provenance, but it's being done in
a fairly ad hoc way.
And in general, for all of these log-based
approaches, if I just take the output of whatever
the computer actually captures, it's generally
too low to be tremendously useful for these
questions of reproducibility and these questions
of trustworthiness and reliability and impact.
And the reason is it captures all the micro-level
steps that a piece of software read 64 bytes
from one file and wrote 32 bytes to another
file and all sorts of information about sequential
steps that may not matter.
It's basically very, very low level at the
level of the operating system reasons about
things rather than the level that we would
like to think about as experimentalists and
so forth.
So what we'd like to do is lift from these
chronological steps in a nod to something
that says this thing was produced because
somebody in particular ran it using the following
steps, and so on.
It's really about causal relationships, not
individual ontological steps.
And the kinds of questions we want to ask
are generally about relationships between
the individual components that were processed,
created, et cetera.
So this is going to motivate us to rethink
our level of abstraction.
If this is too low level, can we come up with
something higher level?
Second big problem is that in general, these
logs get really, really irregular.
It's hard to process logs from different software
artifacts, because they just end up looking
completely different.
So a second goal as we think about provenance
is we need a standard way of capturing provenance
no matter where it came from, what systems,
et cetera.
So summary of this first part-- provenance,
we can break it into two main components.
The first is taking raw data, capturing the
who, what, where, why, and how.
This is primarily a data design, and then
ultimately a human plus
automated data entry task.
This step is, of course, extraordinarily important.
But in many data science scenarios, what we
will end up sharing and reusing may not be
the raw data.
It might be some kind of derived data.
So our focus, and especially the focus of
computer scientists like me, is on computational
support for provenance on derived data.
And this is really about capturing the individual
steps, the inputs, the conditions, and so
on for each of the processing stages and really
describing not just fields, but relationships
among the individual data products.
Ideally, we'd do this completely automatically,
transparently, invisible to the scientist.
In the worst case, we will do it semi-automatically
with the scientist potentially helping out
a little bit with providing extra details.
Other big piece is we want to make sure that
any computational support here has standards
and a way that provenance is captured generically,
but then it's also extensible so that specific
fields, specific metadata can be added for
a given domain.
Finally, it's worth noting our goals, again,
are reproducibility, assessment of quality,
harmonization, and so forth.
So let's now take the goals from this first
segment and look at how we might refine the
straw man approach into something a little
more suitable for reasoning about.
And coming from the database community, we
tend to think a lot about data models, like
the relational data model or a graph data
model.
Similarly, what we want here is a provenance
data model or a provenance model, and that's
basically what we're going to be talking about
next.
So broadly, if we look at what we're trying
to capture in data provenance, there are really
three main components.
There are entities, which are the things that
are being manipulated.
So typically, that could be something like
a data file or a data object within a file
or a data object within a data stream from
a sensor.
Somehow or other, you have these things being
fed into processing steps.
And as a result, other entities are being
produced.
So the first component is entities.
The second thing is some of the entities--
for instance, pieces of code-- might be run
as tasks and might be used to process data.
So we have this generic idea of activities.
Some of the activities might be processed
by humans, so conducting some particular manual
step in processing is definitely an activity,
and we might want to abstract that.
And obviously, a lot of the activities are
going to be running software artifacts, which
really are, at some level, binary files with
particular versions and timestamps and so
on.
We're going to be running those and processing
input entities or files using particular parameters.
So activities really represent not a piece
of code or a particular kind of noun in the
system, but rather, the act of doing some
task, either computationally or manually.
And then finally, we have agents, who typically
are people.
The activities are going to be invoked by
the people.
But sometimes, also, you will have situations
where a person starts one particular computational
job and then spawns a bunch of others.
So agents can be both humans, but they can
also be other tasks that then go on and invoke
still other tasks and so on.
So agents basically start activities, or put
the other way, activities are usually conducted
on behalf of or by agents.
Activities typically read entities and write
entities, or more generically, they have entities
that they process in order to produce other
entities.
So on the bottom of this slide, we have a
figure which shows, again, our gene sequencing
example where we see sequence data which is
an entity.
It's annotated by metadata.
Sorry.
And at the next step, we have this ellipse
represents the quality check activity, which
has some parameters.
And in fact, not shown here, the quality check
presumably also links to the particular file
that is the program being run.
The quality check is being performed by our
user.
So here we have the little house symbol with
Bill Nye the Science Guy in it.
Perhaps he ran the quality check code.
The output of that will be these filtered
sequences, which again, is an entity.
Then we run an aligner, which takes the filtered
sequences in a reference genome as input entities,
and it produces alignments.
That's essentially an abstract representation
of provenance.
And in fact, I'm broadly following the notation
of one of the standards that we're going to
talk about in a moment.
One thing that's interesting about the standard
is that the arrows point in the opposite direction
of data flow.
So if you read this diagram initially, you
may get the impression that data is going
from right to left.
But in fact, in general, these edges, the
lines, and the arrows represent where things
came from as opposed to where data was sent.
So we're really looking at the alignments
were created by the aligner, which read as
an input the filtered sequences.
More generically, this standard, which at
this point has had a lot of input from many
different constituencies and has become the
standard for data provenance, called PROV-DM,
the Provenance Data Model, is standardized
by the World Wide Web Consortium, and it's
actually one of a family of provenance standards.
It basically defines a syntax, an abstract
representation, and a basic vocabulary for
core aspects of data provenance.
And so you'll see in the table on the left
this notion of entities, activities, and agents
that I had used in the previous example.
Underneath that, there is a series of relationships
between these entities, activities, and agents,
so things like something was generated by
a particular activity, or that an agent used
a particular entity, or that one particular
entity was derived from another, et cetera.
So this is a basic core vocabulary for relationships
between data items.
On the right, we see some examples of different
views of provenance graphs describing these
relationships.
It's worth noting that all of the white boxes
in those figures describe extra properties.
This is metadata that's specific
to the domain that the data was acquired from.
So these are the metadata fields that you
would customize for your particular experiment
or data modality or data types.
PROV tries to give a basic core for describing
entities, activities, agents, and relationships
and assumes that you will augment all of that
with additional domain-specific fields that
hopefully will be propagated in a straightforward
way from inputs to outputs and so on.
So that's the basic core way of capturing
provenance in a general way that is also extensible.
And in many ways, I like to make the analogy--
even though it's not an exact one-- that one
should think of PROVDM much the way one thinks
of standards like XML or JSON or RDF, which
is to say there is a core syntax that helps
us share a lot of the basic concepts, but
ultimately, there will be extra fields, metadata,
and relationships that you will need to define
and add as you go.
Just to give some hint on how PROV-DM is actually
entered into the computer, there are several
different formats.
One of them is called PROV-N. It's designed
to be fairly human readable.
So what we see in the example here is the
definition of a bunch of entities.
So the first entity is some kind of article,
and we're assigning particular metadata fields,
like a title, to that particular entity.
Those things that you see before the colons--
the EXN and the DC terms and so on-- are part
of what's called a namespace.
It's a place where individual terms are being
defined, for instance, within an ontology
or within a particular schema.
So for the most part, you can ignore that
prefix and just read this as we're defining
an entity which is an article, and it has
a title being crime rises in cities.
We have similar definitions here for dataset
1 and region list and so on.
There is also an XML equivalent format for
those who are building tools.
As you can hopefully get from the example,
it's much less human readable.
But the advantage to XML is that there are
many, many tools that automatically generate,
parse, and read it.
So that's what provenance looks like, ultimately.
There's this abstract model of graphs between
users, agents, and activities, and then there's
this more syntactic model, which is just how
we encode the basic objects and relationships
within the graph.
The next question, obviously, should be we
have this model, how in the world are we actually
going to record, in particular, the provenance
relationships.
So there are really three main ways.
If you write a particular analytics algorithm,
then one thing that you could do-although
it takes a fair amount of work-- would be
to have the program itself not only produce
the output data files, but in fact, record
somewhere, for instance, a bunch of PROV-N
or PROV-XML records describing exactly what
it did.
But that's fairly labor intensive, and especially
for code that already exists, most people
will not be particularly motivated to add
this extra instrumentation.
So a second thing you can do-- and this has
been the common practice within a lot of the
scientific communities, especially in areas
like physics and astronomy where there are
very regular processing workflows done-- there
are special platforms, like Taverna and Kepler
and Galaxy and VisTrails-- which basically
allow you to define sequences of computation
using a boxes and arrows dataflow module.
Actually, the [INAUDIBLE] effort also does
something similar to this, where different
computational steps can be cascaded together,
usually using visual tools, and these will
be automatically run on a server somewhere.
And many of the existing workflow engines,
as a byproduct, will automatically generate
data provenance to go along with the data
outputs.
And this is a wonderful and extremely helpful
capability.
However, there are a number of people-- and
I would count among that many of my collaborators--
who feel that a large part of their data analysis
is not regular enough that they want to use
a workflow system.
Rather, they want to be able to go, for instance,
to the Python Shell and run a bunch of particular
steps.
Or they might want to go to the Linux terminal
and run different programs to do some sequence
of steps, and they might want to be able to
change this on the fly.
So for these kinds of scenarios, to this point,
there have not been very many answers for
how to actually capture that kind of provenance.
In recent years, there have been a number
of efforts to try to actually build tools
that help capture arbitrary executions of
programs and scripts and so on.
So at NYU Poly, Juliana Freire's group has
done a bunch of work in this space.
And as I had mentioned earlier, our group
here has also done something in this space
to allow for a background, Dropbox-like tool
that just watches what you're running, and
records it, and generates PROV-DM.
So I'll talk more about this, again, in a
little bit.
So that was what provenance looks like, how
we actually record it.
The last piece to provenance capture is where
do we actually put it once we have it there.
Again, I want to emphasize that one shouldn't
really think of provenance and data as living
in completely different worlds.
However, we typically have a solution for
where we're storing our data, and it may not
be easy to gracefully extend that to support
provenance.
So in general, the way we think of provenance
storage is somewhere, we ought to have a provenance
database which will really be strong graphs,
and there ought to be a way of having common
identifiers between nodes in our traditional
database or data storage system and references
in the provenance storage system so that we
can reconstruct the links between provenance
and data.
Often, when people hear that provenance and
PROV-DM are a graph, we'll pretty quickly
gravitate toward graph databases, so things
like Neo4j and OrientDB and so on.
And that's a perfectly good and viable place
to put provenance.
But in fact, one can also encode provenance
in essentially any kind of NoSQL database,
or relational databases, where the tables
would be things like entities and attributes
and agents, et cetera.
So prov does not
particularly prescribe what the underlying
database is.
However, it does pretty well prescribe what
we want to store within the database.
And here, there are a lot of tools that have
been built from the PROV-DM spec.
In particular, Luc Moreau, who was one of
the core leaders of the prov movement, has
a very nice prov toolbox in open source.
And a variety of groups, including ours, have
built expanded services over that for trying
to capture provenance from the community.
So we, for instance, have a server called
pennprovenance.net where you can just upload,
share, and manage PROV-DM data.
What I described so far is looking at provenance
in terms of files and computational modules,
so things like programs.
In reality, that is one piece of the broad
spectrum of how computer scientists think
about provenance.
There are a lot of efforts in trying to model
provenance at a finer level of granularity
than files and programs.
So for instance, I might look at my file that
had lists of gene sequences and want to specifically
describe each of those sequences as a separate
input entity.
And I might want to think about my aligner
program as having individual sub-steps.
So we tend to think of this as going from
treating files and programs as black boxes
that we don't understand into making them
clear boxes or gray boxes or white boxes where
you can actually algorithmically reason about
what's going on in terms of the individual
data objects, the contents, and in terms of
the individual operations.
And if you go to this level of detail, which
has been studied heavily in the database community
and others, this lets you reason in much more
detail about how specific results as opposed
to specific files, how those were produced.
And it can also, in many cases, help diagnose
why some results might be different from others,
and so forth.
So broadly, I think it's important to understand
that from the life sciences perspective, we'll
often think about file to program to file
provenance, black box provenance.
But there are situations where we need this
lower level of detail or finer level of detail,
and there are technologies for that as well.
That's not going to be the focus of my presentation
here, but there are many references in that.
And in the Q&A or in other scenarios, I'm
happy to talk about this in more detail.
So to summarize part 2, we've gone from this
notion of why we want to capture provenance
to the basic core constructs of how people
encode provenance abstractly as entities,
activities, and agents.
We talked a bit about the PROV-DM standard
and the fact that it captures data flows and
relationships, but allows additional metadata
to be attached.
We talked a bit about different tools and
mechanisms for capturing provenance, and then
we highlighted the notion that actually, there
are also other, more detailed forms of the
data provenance.
As the last major segment, what I want to
do is talk briefly about some of the computational
tasks that people are
doing or attempting to develop techniques
to do with data provenance.
So one of the most common things, and one
of the most commonly supported things that
we can do, is to take data items-- so again,
files or individual records-- and to build
tools that will help look up the provenance
of those particular objects and visualize
it so that users can sanity check, can reproduce,
can identify why and how a particular data
item existed.
So this broadly is useful for sanity checking,
interpretation, and so on at the manual level.
And it's not an uncommon operation at all,
especially if you want to reproduce results.
But in many ways, this is the simplest thing,
because what it really involves is looking
up the provenance, the PROV-DM entry for a
given entity, pulling up that piece of the
graph, and then running it through interactive
visualization tools, like the one that I'm
showing here, and a wide variety of tools
that are available to the community.
While we're talking about this, I should also
mention, a question may come up if you're
trying to do reproducible research, and especially
if you're trying to authenticate a result--
how do we know that what we're visualizing
is actually what was done?
What if somebody came into our provenance
database and hacked the provenance entries?
Well, it turns out there are a bunch of pieces
of work in the computer science space-- in
fact, done by my colleagues here at Penn--
specifically developing ways of using encryption
and so-called Merkle trees to help capture
the individual steps and essentially authenticate
that the provenance is intact and has not
been forged or modified in any given way.
So that's provenance and its visualization.
Some other things that we might want to do
are what I want to focus on for the last couple
of minutes.
I want to emphasize here that most of the
things I'm going to briefly talk about are
on the active research side of the world.
There are some preliminary tools for many
of them.
But many of them are highly dependent on exactly
what level of detail we have in terms of the
black box operations and how they work.
And because they're so dramatically affected
by the individual assumptions of the operations,
the number of tools available that are general
purpose is a bit more limited here.
So these are all areas where I think we're
going to start to see more and more tooling
and more and more options as the next couple
of years go forward.
So first piece I'm going to mention is we
might go from visualizing provenance to reproduction
to actually using provenance and automating
the process of reproducing an experiment.
So basically, this involves, for instance,
having a tool where the user can identify
some particular data product and say can you
repeat the same process that was involved
in creating this data product on my new input
data item over here.
So this is now really taking the provenance
and using it, essentially, to define a script
to run against another new piece of data.
And then we can further expand on that to
say why don't we reproduce and rerun exactly
the script that was used
on the previous result with one small modification.
So for instance, I want to replace one of
the original modules with my own module, and
now I want to compare the results.
So this task of automating the reproduction
and ultimately comparison and benchmarking
of different results is something that's computationally
fairly easy to do, but can be incredibly effective
as part of the exploration and reproduction
repertoire for scientists.
Another big piece, and one of my personal
interests, is this interplay between data
provenance and both trustworthiness of the
data and impact.
So I had alluded a bit to this earlier.
If we look at all of our data in some PROV-DM
graph, ultimately, what will happen is certain
entities will be re-used in many, many, many
experiments, and perhaps the results of those
experiments can be reused in many, many other
analyses, and so on.
And if we have a bird's eye perspective of
what's being reused, this gives us a wonderful
opportunity to assign scores to impact and
centrality and visibility of particular data
items.
And in the same way that we tend to use things
like the h-index for measuring scholarly impact
or page rank for measuring authoritativeness
of websites, we can create a sharing index
or an impact index on data based on who is
using it.
And the building block to that is data provenance.
Another big piece that's closely related but
now focuses on single items as opposed to
the entire network of relationships is over
time, as we look at data and assess whether
it is correct or incorrect, we can use machine
learning and other techniques to figure out
between all the data items that are correct
and all the data items that are incorrect,
or between all the data items that are relevant
and those that are irrelevant, what is it
in their provenance that differentiates between
the good and the bad or the trusted and untrusted.
And over time, we can actually learn to put
weights and scores and probabilities of relevance
on data based purely on its provenance.
So that's something that I think will continue
to become more and more important over time
as more data becomes shared and reused in
more and more and more experiments.
Really, the last main piece I wanted to briefly
allude to is provenance is also a building
block toward diagnosis and debugging.
I have collaborators who run, essentially,
scripts over their data on a daily basis.
They are acquiring new data every day.
They run a script.
They produce some results.
Over time, they make tweaks to the script.
Over time, they might want to do a historical
comparison of their results from today versus
the results from six months.
And sometimes, the results aren't consistent.
Now the question is how do they diagnose what
changed and why.
And there, absolutely data provenance becomes
critical to really identifying the differences
between today's script and six months ago's
script.
And in fact, we can replay pieces of those
two scripts and compare them in order to ultimately
help the scientist to debug what changed and
potentially what went wrong in their analysis.
So this is something that we're very, very
interested in and actively working on here
at Penn.
One last part related to provenance that's
worth emphasizing before we conclude is that
while I talked about going from this very
low level view of provenance to something
more abstract, in fact, there are many possible
levels of abstraction I might want to have
for provenance.
In some cases, I want to see each individual
step.
In some places, I may want to actually simplify
or collapse together many provenance steps
into one unified black box.
So one of the big tasks in this view of ultimately
building a provenance database or provenance
support platform is we want to be able to
do queries and views that actually abstract
data.
And a lot of work done by my colleague Susan
Davidson has actually focused especially on
those particular problems.
So in terms of making provenance useful, we
can visualize it.
We can use it to measure trust and impact.
We can use it to measure differences between
different results, and we can use it to hide
and abstract pieces of provenance and give
us a better perspective on what really happened.
So let me wrap up now by saying I have tried
to capture, through the last 50 minutes, why
provenance is actually a hard problem, and
it's more than just defining that there are
data acquisition parameters.
We described a bit about how we model provenance
abstractly, some of the tools and techniques
available for capture, some of the tools and
techniques available are under active study
for what we can do with provenance.
I've mentioned along the way that as part
of our NIH BD2K project, we've been trying
to build reusable tools for the community
in this space.
So I'll leave a pointer up for that.
And I want to conclude by saying provenance
is still a space that is in its early stages.
There is tremendous opportunity for using
this kind of metadata for reasoning about
data.
And I'm very excited about where it's all
headed, and I expect in five years a repeat
version of this webinar will end up looking
dramatically different as we start to have
impact.
So thank you for your time, and I'm happy
to flip to Q&A mode as people have questions.
Wonderful.
Thank you so much, Zach.
That was outstanding.
So everyone, if you do have some questions
for Dr. Ives, please enter them into the little
question functionality there that's part of
the Go To Webinar interface, probably on the
right side of your screen, and we'll try and
get to those.
Now, we've already had a few of these.
And Zach, one person asked how much activity
is going on with the level of manufacturers
to make sure that critical provenance information,
such as the firmware or the make, model, and
serial number of the scanner or the gene sequencer
or whatever, is getting embedded into raw
data files so that-- it's almost like-- it
there a minimum information standard that's
available, and are manufacturers subscribing
to it?
So that's a wonderful question, and I would
say it's highly, highly variable by communities.
So it seems like there
are certain domains where most of that information
does seem to be getting captured.
I think there are also plenty of cases where
it's clear that that's not all being captured.
It feels like this is one of the things that,
at the end of the day, the research community
needs to articulate strongly to the manufacturers
that part of what's going to help us select
your instrument will be that it records all
this kind of information.
I suspect there are a lot of cases where people
have firmware that you will never see that
that particular firmware got changed or whatnot.
Many of the other parameters, I think, are
being captured and are available, at least
in the manufacturer's file formats.
I think the other thing that's always a bit
tricky is depending on the field, sometimes
there is a level of detail that is output
by the instruments in their proprietary file
formats, but then once you export that data
into some more open format, a lot of that
detail tends to get dropped.
So I think there's also an opportunity to
think about for specific data modalities,
are there things that we want to encourage
everybody to propagate from the individual
devices.
And you also mentioned that you don't want
provenance to be a burden for researchers.
With the exception of the manufacturers helping
us to do it, do you see any other way to achieve
it being a simple thing for people to do,
and are there any editors or things that people
can use to help store their provenance?
That's a great question, and it has many,
many different answers.
So I will mention I remember that the Case
Western Data Provenance Project that's going
on in BD2K right now, Satya Sahoo's group,
one of the things that they're actually working
on is trying to have forms and capture of
provenance as doctors see patients.
That ends up being something that has to be
manually entered.
There has been a lot of work in, for instance,
digital lab notebooks that use tablets.
And one of the opportunities there, although
it's still fledgling, is if you have an iPad
and there are, for instance, barcodes or RFIDs
or Bluetooth transponders or various other
devices on, for instance, things in the physical
world, you can imagine extending your digital
lab notebook to record all of those individual
things.
So as we move to this future internet of things
world where all of your instruments can talk,
I suspect we're going to see more and more
automatic data acquisition for these kinds
of sensors, and what was used, and so on.
Again, things like tablets would probably
help also as we switch from physical lab notebooks.
But unfortunately, there is also no magic
wand technology here that's going to completely
eliminate the human as the conduit for a huge
part of that knowledge.
That being said, I think as particular tasks
mature, there probably will be more and more
automation of specific steps there.
Right.
What role do you see librarians and archivists,
basically part of the digital archiving community--
what role
can they play in helping scientists and data
scientists to do this in an effective way?
I think that's one of the great opportunities
for the library and information science community,
is really helping to define and assist with
best practices and metadata, potentially actually
aiding with the maintenance of archives, and
so on.
I will say from my own interactions with,
for instance, our university librarians versus
the libraries in other universities, it's
still very much an open question of just how
central libraries are going to be in this
picture.
I personally think this seems like a great
role for them.
And there are a lot of really talented people
in those fields who are working broadly in
this space and broadly in digital curation,
and digital citation, and so on.
So my hope is that that will be among their
central roles looking forward.
But it also feels like that is happening for
some, but not all, institutions at this point
in time.
Great.
One final question for you-- is there any
way-- and perhaps you discussed some of this,
but maybe you want to elaborate-- is there
any way to fingerprint data and its metadata
and its provenance in such a way that there's
a unique identifier?
Perhaps it's some sort of a hash number that
can be a unique identifier that can also help
you to make sure that data hasn't been tampered
with or altered in any way?
Yeah.
So in fact, absolutely that is the case.
There are many cryptographic hash algorithms
that people commonly use over the data to
generate unique IDs.
Sometimes, that ID itself is what is shared.
Sometimes, that ID becomes a signature or
certificate on the data.
One of the challenges tends to be that at
times, those signatures themselves are fairly
large.
At times, there is a question of how you would
create a signature or to look up a data item
if you don't know all of its fields.
So I think this is an extremely important
building block toward that.
I think also, coming back to the point of
security, I think one of the other pieces
that we have to take into account is often,
I'll acquire some data, I'll do an experiment,
I'll produce an output.
I might hash or assign that output, then I
give it to somebody else, who in turn does
the same thing, and so on.
And so really, you're building a, if you will,
a Russian doll of nested one thing inside
of another inside of another.
And so cryptography helps us tremendously
with that.
But one of the major challenges there becomes
how do you look up the cryptographic key of
a particular data item that you know exists
if you don't have the key in the first place.
So it's really important and useful, and a
critical building block, but one has to realize
that also, there are some particular use cases
that it doesn't support.
OK.
Wonderful.
Dr. Ives, thank you so much for giving us
a great talk on provenance and all that that
entails.
I want to thank everybody who joined us this
morning.
And if you do have further questions, I'm
sure Dr. Ives-- you can go to his website
there and find out how to get in touch with
him and ask him your questions.
Tune in again next week, everyone, for our
data science seminar series.
We look forward to having you.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Enjoy your weekend.